an MSNBC panel declares the GOP is the
party of white men you will be shocked
to learn it turns out that MSNBC has
gotten it exactly wrong then two
Democrat white men Joe Biden and Michael
avenatti disappoint the nation when they
declare their individual intentions for
the 2020 presidential election the
Princeton student newspaper accuses a
Disney song of promoting rape and
misogyny College leftists fake a hate
crime and Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
continues to fail at basic math I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Noel's Oh
[Music]
is the GOP the party of white men this
swarthy Republican man this slightly
off-white taupe beige Republican man
will analyze so all of that in a second
because the person who said this on
MSNBC has it exactly wrong and the
numbers back that up
but first speaking of numbers backing
things up let the numbers back you up
with Lending Club Oh Lending Club for
decades credit cards have been telling
us to buy it now pay for it later with
interest especially Christmas season is
coming along you're gonna be racking up
those bills despite your best intentions
that interest can get out of control
fast with Lending Club you can
consolidate your debt or pay off credit
cards with one fixed monthly payment
since 2007 Lending Club has helped
millions of people regain control of
their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to
the bank no high interest credit cards
just go to Lending Club com tell them
about yourself how much you want to
borrow pick the terms that are right
from you if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days you
don't need to think about anything it's
the number one peer-to-peer lending
platform with over 35 billion the
billion with a beat in loans issued go
to Lending Club comm slash anoles Canada
wles check your rate in minutes borrow
up to 40 grand that's my gift to you for
Christmas is $40,000 Lending Club comm
slash Knowles kano wles
Lending Club back on slash Knowles ano
wles
all loans made by webb bank member FDIC
Equal Housing lender is the GOP the
party of white men this is what an MSNBC
panel and Abie Stoddard on that panel is
insisting here they are Republican Party
a B and you've been talking with folks
since the midterms where they dropped a
lot of seats there's no other way to put
it but it's Jonathan Martin write to the
New York Times this morning there's not
a lot of signs of course corruption
inside the Republican Party moving
forward right what Jonathan points out
and what these Republicans are talking
about privately is is a new delineation
a realignment that makes them the party
of white men this is a huge loss the
fact that women are so repelled by Trump
in the suburbs and moderate voters and
independent voters a majority is not
made by your base alone and they took a
beating across the board except for
largely white men I love when people
tell us about the
course crap we need a course correction
the GOP wins in 2010 we take the house
2014 we take the Senate between that
time we take all of the state houses
then 2016 we win the presidency and then
in the 2018 midterms we don't lose by as
much as previous presidents have by as
much as Barack Obama as much as Bill
Clinton as much as Ronald Reagan and now
they tell us we need a course correction
I think the course is going just fine
it's going just fine it's true
Republicans lost the house in 2018 that
was very frustrating it wasn't by fifty
seats it wasn't by sixty three seats
like Barack Obama lost but we yeah we
lost the house that's too bad we also
picked up seats in the Senate we also
held on to Florida we flipped a Senate
seat in Florida and we we took the
governor's mansion in Florida this is
what why do we need a course correction
what they're trying to do what the media
trying to do is paint the GOP as the
party of white men this was the whole
line during the 2016 election about the
alt-right the alternative right I've
talked about the all right
I did a Praeger video on the all right
I've talked to the leaders of the
alt-right the alt-right is like 20
people are the alt-right concerned with
race or they racist people yes or is the
alt-right concerned with white
nationalism white identity politics yes
how many of them are there very very few
when they had their March in DC they
mustered about 20 people there when they
had their National Conference they
always get a hundred to 200 people
they've gotten that for years that's
still what they get that's their
National Conference in the whole country
those are the people that they find so
what is it in the in the numbers because
the line from the midterm elections was
that the GOP lost all the suburban
people they won all those awful racist
rural people and they never had a chance
at all those Democrat urban people but
the suburbs that's where the reasonable
people are and the GOP lost them sure
the GOP did lose some suburban seats but
the numbers don't really bear that out
first of all in 2016 the majority of
white women voted for Donald Trump over
Hillary Clinton 52% of white women voted
for Trump over Hillary so that at least
makes me think this isn't just the party
of white men we've also got some white
women how about on every other race and
demographic when you compare Donald
Trump
to Mitt Romney Donald Trump got a higher
percentage of the vote of black men
black women Latino women about the same
vote within one percentage point of
Latino men and and Democrats have have
seen their numbers among those
demographics decline so Trump does
better than Mitt Romney on virtually
every minority demographic and he and he
does well with white women just as a B
Stoddard is saying this just as MSNBC is
saying this Politico comes out with a
piece called Democrats Hispanic problem
because Democrats do have a Hispanic
problem you know when Trump descends the
elevator in 2015 he says he launches his
whole campaign by saying we've got awful
people pouring across the border they're
murderers they're rapists some of them I
assume are good people but most of them
are terrible we're told oh he's gonna
lose the whole Hispanic vote and he does
better with Latino women at least then
Mitt Romney does and he performs about
the same as Mitt Romney so what is that
if it doesn't seem to me that with the
GOP is only focusing on white men but in
2018 in the midterm elections Democrats
got 54% of the Hispanic vote that's not
a lot I mean that for Democrats that's
not a blow-out majority far from it but
what about in 2016 when Donald Trump was
on the ballot Democrats got 62% of the
Hispanic vote in 2015 Democrats got 58%
of the Hispanic vote so if you look at
those two elections in 2018 Republicans
did better with Hispanics than the
Democrats did in terms of momentum not
as a total percentage of the vote but in
terms of the momentum the momentum is
moving toward the GOP so I don't know
where they get this I sometimes think
that the people who go on these panels
all the time I guess I go on these
panels too but so many of these people
especially the ones who live in DC they
just live in a narrative they've can
concocted a narrative of how reality
should be but the numbers don't bear
that out we can we can test these things
we know that that is the case and I'll
tell you something I was walking down
New York I was in New York this past
weekend for a little bit I'm walking
down the street and there was this
Hispanic guy had a very thick accent out
of the blue he turns to me we're walk I
don't think he recognized me I think he
was just talking he was kind of a
boisterous New Yorker type
and he said I couldn't make out all of
his words but he said you got a vote for
Donald Trump you've got a vote for
Donald Trump yeah and I don't he was he
had the newspaper in his hand so I guess
there was something about Trump in the
newspaper said oh yeah well I rather
like Donald Trump you see you've got a
vote what they're doing to him is so
wrong it's so awful and I we were
walking on the street so I didn't have
time to ask him why he thought that but
I talked to cab drivers I talked to
people that I encounter just when I'm
traveling I travel a lot and I find a
lot of people not just white men a lot
of people Hispanic men and women black
men women say they like the guy and they
say it in this I don't exactly know why
but they really like it Kanye West when
he was talking about this said he really
liked the masculine energy of Donald
Trump and I think there is something to
be said for that there is something to
be said that this the soy boy culture
you know the the soy boy beta male want
to use whatever euphemism you want a
vegan they call them herbivores in Japan
you know what whatever that is
that is a culture that is largely
confined to over educated coastal white
guys that is that is the stereotype when
you think of the stereotypical pajama
boy he looks like pajama boy he is the
guy he's sitting there he's a little
white kid with you know he's in his 20s
and he's sitting on the couch bundled up
with a cup of cocoa that is the
demographic demographic that you think
of so maybe people on the coasts think
this may be people who go to cocktail
parties who went to fancy schools but I
don't think this is the case for the
majority of Americans and when you just
look at exit polling from recent
elections that bears that out and it's
also very funny because in the same day
that we're being told that the
Republican Party is the party of white
men and even that even on that number
you know we know that President Trump
support among black men has doubled
during his presidency we see this
whenever President Trump is speaking
he's speaking about all Americans all
Americans bleed the same blood of
patriots it's all red white and blue
huzzah huzzah so you don't see Trump
speaking to it I don't see other Senate
Republicans speaking to it or House
Republicans I think this is just a
fantasy cooked up by Democrats and we
also know that Democrats project all of
the time so whenever they have a worry
about something they
act Democrats are the party of racism
they're the party of slavery the party
of Jim Crow the party that voted for
civil rights at a lower rate than
Republicans did the party that has one
civil rights act - compared to
Republicans six civil rights acts that
we've passed as late as 1991 and so
they're projecting all the time and just
this same day that they're talking about
had Republicans in the party of white
man you've got Michael avenatti and Joe
Biden both discussing whether or not
they're going to run for president and
this is really sad because because in
this case the Democrats took one small
step away from being the party of white
man Michael avenatti creepy porn lawyer
is not going to run for president in
2020 when I saw this I just I woke up
this morning was reading on his tear
just right down my face
ELISA turns to me Mac what's wrong oh no
it's it's nothing it's we're gonna miss
out on a wonderful 20/20 campaign and it
was such a tease Michael avenatti said
just yesterday he said quote I think the
field is shaping up to be even more
advantageous for someone like me not
less I think my chances have only gone
up not down he was asked about the
Senate Michael avenatti was arrested for
beating his girlfriend the other day and
he said I think I'm much more likely to
get the Democrat nomination now and he's
probably right to get the Democrat
nomination
you have to abuse women and steal from
charities and Michael avenatti was
accused of doing that just two weeks ago
so I think he was right I think his
chances went way up today he crushed all
of our dreams Michael avenatti said
quote after consultation with my family
and at their request I have decided not
to seek the presidency of the United
States in 2020 I do not make this
decision lightly I make it out of
respect for my family but for their
concerns I would run so what this really
means is I don't want to be subject to
the exposure of my terrible character
when I run for office because when you
run for office there are whole staffs of
people whose job it is to dig up every
awful thing you ever did and ruin your
life and Michael avenatti has done a lot
of terrible things just in the last 48
hours you know I mean I we're not even
going back that far I love when he talks
about his family that we'll get into
we'll get into the what would have come
out about Michael have a not even one
second but first
speaking of privacy concerns and people
trying to dig up all the awful things
that you do what are you looking at on
the Internet
you're looking at this show that's
enough to get you fired from work with
all the recent news about online
security breaches it's hard not to worry
about where your data goes making an
online purchase or simply accessing your
email could put your private information
at risk we now know there was another
major hack of an institution last week a
lot of information out there you are
being tracked online by social media
sites marketing companies and your
mobile or internet provider which is why
I decided to take back my privacy
using expressvpn it's expressvpn easy to
use apps they run seamlessly in the
background of the computer phone and
tablet turning it on takes only one
click it secures and anonymizes your
internet browsing by encrypting your
data and hiding your public IP address
protect yourself I'm telling you you can
do it for less than seven bucks a month
it will be so it's less than an
expensive coffee you know sort of two
coffees at least and it's it's such a
good investment you've got to watch out
for your privacy it costs virtually
nothing protect your online activity
today find out how to get three months
free expressvpn comm slash michael mi CH
AE l that's exp re SS VPN comm slash
michael mi CH AE l for three months free
with a one-year package visit expressvpn
comm slash michael to learn more if only
michael avenatti had used expressvpn he
might be able to run for president now
because he's got a lot of skeletons in
his closet but i couldn't get over him
saying I've got to look out for my
family this guy has been twice married
twice divorced he was arrested last week
for beating a girlfriend this talk about
your family this is what people say you
know I tried to get mitch Daniels to run
for president in 2012 we did a student
draft movement we had 70 chapters across
the country I thought he was a great
candidate social conservative excellent
fiscally brilliant governor o best
governor in the country and he didn't
run for president because of his family
he'd had this issue in his family where
his wife had basically taken up and
abandoned the family going off to
California somewhere eventually she came
back they got back together and
continued to raise their kids so he
always said if you like happy endings
you'll love our story and that worked
for me but he didn't want to subject his
wife and his family to the awful
scrutiny of Barbara Walters sitting
there across asking his family
why they broke up for a period of time
and I get it I totally understand that
and that's what that's what avenatti is
saying here except with avenatti it's
he's not trying to cover up for what his
wife did he's trying to cover up what
what he is doing he is obviously not
able to withstand that kind of pressure
avenatti and Trump in many ways are
parallel people they're boisterous New
York types the rough-and-tumble married
multiple times you know but the thing is
Donald Trump is always basically willing
to take the bullets for his past
transgressions he's always willing to do
it he's not gonna shrink away from a
public duty because he was a playboy for
the last 30 years
Mike 11 odd he seems to be doing that
it's really sad he would have just been
an amazing amazing candidate in 2020
this you know the the ratings would have
gone 10% higher it's like the wall it
would really only gone it would have
been such a great addition to this
reality show but we're not gonna get him
on the flip side we are going to get
another white male to run for the
Democrat Party this is almost certain
Joe Biden the former vice president of
United States long time senator from
Delaware Joe Biden says without a doubt
he is the most qualified person to
become president now for those of you
who are unfamiliar with Joe Biden Paul
Joseph Watson put together just a little
compilation of some some highlights from
Joe Biden's career you might remember
here is a creepy Joe Biden latching on
every young girl that he can possibly
see iDEN leans uncomfortably close to a
13 year old girl whispers something in
her ear then tries to kiss her as she
instinctively jerks away
he then asks for a picture with the girl
alone senator Jim Risch then says dad's
going to stand pretty close Biden
appears to tell the girl quo if I was
young in this clip Biden kisses a young
girl three times as she squirms
uncomfortably while he says don't tell
anybody don't tell anybody you know
right now the left is all upset about
the song baby it's cold outside they're
all upset about kiss the girl from
Disney they say this promotes a culture
of you know rape culture and no consent
you know look at that clip because we
all remember these we saw him a little
little clip of creepy Uncle Joe and I
think it's very easy to just write it
off as he's a kind of doddering old man
and kind of a straighten it it is really
creepy when you actually watch the poll
Joseph Watson video goes on for like 10
minutes or something he's leaning in
kissing these little girls on the neck
all the fathers are saying basically no
get away from my daughter I'm gonna
stand close it is very weird so anyway
that'll be fun to look forward to I'm
very excited about that if we don't get
Michael avenatti if the Democrats don't
nominate an alleged girlfriend beating a
charity embezzling dirtbag from New York
at least we'll get Joe Biden whose other
claims to fame are being a plagiarist
having to drop out of the Democrat
nomination race 30 years ago because he
was caught plagiarizing and of referring
to Barack Obama as the first clean and
articulate african-american candidate if
you don't remember it nobody remembers
this because because Joe Biden and Obama
are BFFs now aren't they they're books
about this there's a there was actually
a novel written a this fiction about how
Barack Obama and Joe Biden they're so
close they solve crimes together I had
to read it because drew Clavin is an a
sadist and decided to subject me to that
but
when they were running Joe Biden
referred to Barack Obama is clean and
articulate here he is he's the first one
we've never had any of those before have
we any clean articulate bright African
Americans can you imagine this guy said
this is the vice president for the
Democrats for Barack Obama imagine if a
Republican said anything even resembling
that if he if a Republican used even one
of those adjectives to describe Barack
Obama he would be thrown in Guantanamo
Bay for hate crimes he would be banned
from every social media platform Joe
Biden gets away with it they let him get
away with it and this is what he said at
this event on his tour II said quote
I'll be as straight with you as I can I
think I'm the most qualified person in
the country to be President this was at
the University of Montana the issues
that we face as a country are the issues
that have been in my wheelhouse that
I've worked on my whole life
Michael avenatti is more qualified to be
President than Joe Biden that is not an
exaggeration
what is Joe Biden ever accomplished what
has he ever done it's true he's been in
public life forever
he's been a sort of sympathetic figure a
likable figure he's obviously a talented
politician he's managed to stick around
a long time what has he done
what's the Biden accomplishment can you
name any I don't name the Trump
accomplishment he put the embassy in
Israel in Jerusalem he reformed taxes he
lowered taxes he renegotiated trade
deals he hopefully will build the wall
he hasn't done that one yet we're
working on it he reinstituted pro-life
policies he defunded SRI defunded
certain agencies and certain aspects of
the United Nations and foreign aid okay
this is all very good stuff there are a
lot and a lot more
what are even among other senators Teddy
Kennedy what did Teddy Kennedy do he got
a major immigration bill through was a
terrible immigration nobody got it
through at least that's an
accomplishment what did Joe Buy
ever do other than run for president and
sit on the Judiciary Committee and look
very uncomfortable during the Clarence
Thomas hearings during the clarence
thomas hearings he's there he's giving
Clarence Thomas a hard time and then
Clarence Thomas uses the phrase
high-tech lynching and Biden puts his
head down he doesn't want to be seen on
camera what has he ever done in politics
other than just be there not very much
that's why he's not a great candidate
for presidents why he's never been
presidents why he's never going to be
the president the and also they say he's
got blue-collar appeal I'll believe it
when I see it
I understand that theoretically Joe
Biden has a blue-collar appeal let's see
let's put those two guys on stage
together because what happens in this
day and age in the social media age the
reality to hit TV age of politics is
that authenticity is is rewarded and
artificiality is not rewarded and this
has often been true in politics but now
more than ever because our screens are
all in 4k we're constantly communicating
with people on Twitter where there's
24-hour news cycle so authenticity
really is recorded and and and rewarded
rather and Joe Biden is one of the most
disingenuous people in politics
he's so unctuous he's so greasy he he
plays a blue-collar guy on TV but does
he really relate to them for a Donald
Trump is a billionaire but I think he
relates to them a lot more especially
when he's sitting on his private jet and
all he ever wants to do is drink diet
coke and eat KFC there's something loves
fast-food he loves he he talks about
money in the way that we all talk about
money cut but not in the way that you
know sophisticates talk about money that
the elite talk about money I think he's
much more relatable you put those two
guys together on stage somewhere in the
Rust Belt Pennsylvania wherever I think
100% Donald Trump would blow that guy
out of the water because Joe Biden is
like the poor man's Donald Trump he
can't I don't think he can put that
through but so he thinks that he's going
to run Bruce Springsteen who is a
Democrat he's a yellow dog Democrat his
Democrat as they come he says nobody out
there at the moment can beat Donald
Trump and I tend to agree with him he
says quote I don't see anyone out there
at the moment the man who can beat Trump
or the woman who can beat Trump you need
someone who can speak some of the same
language as Trump and the Democrats do
have an obvious affective presidential
candidate actually the guy who can speak
the same language as Trump is Michael
avenatti he is the guy he speaks like a
New Yorker he's tough he uses Italian
words he only knows like four Italian
words but he uses them you know Busta
sort of things and he punches really
hard he is apparently shameless he's got
a little bit of shame now which is why I
guess he's not gonna run but he broadly
as shameless he represents porn stars
steals their money beats women he's a
shameless guy he he really probably does
have that oomph and he's he's taken the
fight to the president unsuccessfully
but at least he's tried other than that
who else is gonna do it who else is
gonna beat Trump so avenatti is out I
guess there's cory booker never gonna
happen never ever gonna happen
he's so the tears of Rage and Spartacus
doesn't play and I the issue Harvey
Mansfield talks about the issue that
Cory Booker is facing right now which is
that he wrote this book called manliness
and he said that people like feminine
women and people can sort of like
masculine women too that's not as that's
not really a big problem people like
masculine men and nobody likes womanish
men they don't like men who are crying
all the time
not womanly woman ish all these bad
stereotypes crying being really
emotional being all this people don't
like that and that's what cory booker is
doing he's falling into this he's
believing the left's press releases
about what we want men to be he's
believing that we want men to be the
sensitive man the the vegan you know the
guy who doesn't ever stand up and exude
some chivalry and be a gentleman and be
a tough guy he's buying that false
narrative and so he goes at the Senate
Judiciary Committee or wherever he goes
on at any Senate testimony rather and he
just whines and he cries and he says he
cries tears of rage and he pretends to
be Spartacus that doesn't play with
anybody nobody likes that women don't
like that men don't like that man's
field and his book said that men who
behave like men or at least to accept
the standards of how men are supposed to
behave despise that sort of activity
it's a natural
Polson and I think that's what we're
seeing in in cory booker's he's not
going anywhere
commonly harris maybe as a chance
because we don't know that much about
her she's very smart she checks a lot of
intersectional boxes so maybe she's got
some chance somewhere but she's
basically untested so we have to see how
she is as a candidate liz warren i think
is for all intents and purposes done
liya watha ain't ain't going very far
Kirsten Gillibrand is the senator from
New York Democrat people some people are
insisting that she's the sleeper
candidate she's not going anywhere the
people who think that Gillibrand is
gonna go somewhere are the people who
were sure that Jeb Bush was gonna win
the nomination there are these
out-of-touch herbin professional people
Gillibrand I don't really see going
anywhere who well there are some sleeper
candidates shared Brown Amy Klobuchar
who knows we'll see but probably Bruce
Springsteen is right right now Donald
Trump for all of his flaws and for all
of the media spotlight that we've got on
his flaws real and imagined right now
he's the guy who's who's leading the
race that's a very good thing and we're
gonna keep seeing that because the left
is only gonna move further to the left I
think they're gonna double down on this
if they were smart they'd try to tack a
little bit to the center get rid of some
of the identity politics and try to take
the fight to Donald Trump instead
they're doubling down on this insanity
there was a great piece today a great
piece in The Daily Princetonian or
something whatever the newspaper is at
Princeton and I bring this up one
because these Ivy League college
newspapers can write insane things and
that's kind of funny but in this case
it's representative of what the left
broadly is talking about the piece in
The Daily Princetonian says that the
song kiss the girl in the Disney movie
this the Little Mermaid is sexist
misogynist and promotes rape culture I
kid you not the saw the the title of it
is dear Tiger tones please stop singing
kiss the girl
I guess tiger tones is the acapella
singing group at Princeton she says
quote even when gently crooned by an
animated crab the song kissed the girl
from the Disney hit the Little Mermaid
is more misogynistic and dismissive of
consent than cute by performing the song
multiple times each semester the tiger
tones elevate it to an offensive and
violating ritual
no matter how great the tradition this
canonical Tiger tones tune should be
struck from their repertoire its lyrics
raised some serious issues the premise
of the song originally sung in the
Little Mermaid is that the male Prince
Erik on a date with the beautiful female
Ariel should kiss her without asking for
a single word to affirm her consent
the horror oh the enormity and the
horror if you don't remember the movie I
haven't seen it since I was five
probably hears the song did you hear
something there is one la la la guess
we're gonna cut the song that's the song
kiss the girl you know and that's how
you find out if she likes you is you try
to kiss the girl and we'll see what
happens so lovely song cute little
number and this this article is
obviously an example of what happens
when some eighteen or nineteen year old
person who doesn't know anything
takes a gender studies class or these
days really any class at a university
and is really examining all of the
problematic unconscious subconscious
awful enormities in our society and then
makes up problems that don't exist but
what is this girl suggesting what is the
left suggesting the left is saying maybe
it's cold outside is a terrible song
it's being taken off of radio stations
it isn't just sophomores at Ivy League
universities doing is it's the whole
whole left-wing in the country
what is she suggesting what she's
suggesting is before a guy kisses a girl
he needs to ask her permission and I
don't I don't want to be too mean about
this but for any of the guys who are at
Princeton reading this article and find
themselves agreeing with it you know 100
percent
they have never kissed a girl you know
maybe they've asked they might have
asked and they've gotten a lot of knows
that's what I think they've gotten that
isn't how it works you know so the what
what feminism wants to do is eliminate
love I that sounds like
outrageous statement major second wave
feminists have said this very fact
surely with Firestone one of the most
influential second wave feminists in
1960s and 70s called that called one of
the most influential by Naomi Wolf
another later a very important feminist
she said that'll love even more than
childbirth is the greatest impediment to
women's liberation the love of men for
women the love of women for men this is
the old line they say there will never
be a gender war because everybody's
sleeping with the enemy
or almost everybody's sleeping with the
enemy and that's what they want to do
they want to eliminate love because what
they want is for the interactions
between the sexes to just be in a
transaction like a business transaction
you signed the consent form you get it
notarized kissed you know you file it
with your lawyer and then you know okay
good now we can okay and can I kiss you
on your cheek and can I kiss you on your
neck but of course that isn't how it
happens
it isn't clinical it isn't this cold
sterile interaction usually you're
having a drink you're going went out
you're at a bar or a club or something
maybe you're a dinner and there's
chemistry that is going on you lean in
and just you're leaning in there with
your date and just before you're about
to make the move you say excuse me is it
okay if I kiss you ma'am just uh not
anymore it's not
it was about five seconds ago but now
it's not and this this is what they want
I mean they want this this cold sterile
interaction between the two George Will
wrote about this a while ago to probably
a he said Cole Porter didn't write let's
do it let's be in a relationship he
didn't he said let's do it let's fall in
love and and you know this is not true
of reality because of all of the rape
allegations on campus because of the
hook-up culture there was a major expose
of the hook-up culture and one student
said the reason that we hook up we get
blackout drunk and hook up is because we
don't have social skills and so they
can't they're not interacting in a
normal way that men and women should
interact so they get blackout drunk to
take away any accountability for their
actions and then they go and hook up
because men and women are gonna go do
that and then they might regret it the
next day and they might say oh I
shouldn't have done that and that this
stems necessarily from that culture and
that culture is
also born of this bizarre idea of the
relationship between men and women
we know that in reality people are not
going right before they kiss you there
on saying excuse me can I kiss you no
that isn't how it works that isn't how
it's supposed to work the flip side of
that is you need to respect people you
need to have social graces with people
you need to read the room and if you
lean in to a girl and you try to kiss
her and then she doesn't want to kiss
you she'll turn away and you'll get a
cheek and too bad then you go try again
and then you've gotten your answer one
way to find out you kiss the girl she
turns away or she gives you a slap or
something too bad you can't kiss her
next time I I don't see this problem
getting better I don't see this moving a
way I don't because what's happening is
our discourse is being divided and
separated more and more from the reality
of the behavior and so we're living in
these lies and we're all giving lip
service to these lies but that isn't the
reality that doesn't help anybody
because if you've attracted us to
sustain that fantasy and they're very
bad results for that and we're seeing
that in the sexual culture on campuses
around the country they're bad results
for the men they're bad results for the
women yeah but there are many other good
things to talk about there are many
other good results but this isn't you
know we've got to obviously talk about
okay as you know quartets that's the
best thing we've got to talk about there
are always these good things but even
you know we're talking about the campus
sexual culture this is true even of race
incidents there are a lot of other hate
crime hoaxes that have been going around
we'll get to that in a second but first
I gotta say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube if you're on daily wire.com
thank you very much you keep the lights
on you keep Kofi Fay in my cup if you're
not there go to daily wire comm it's ten
bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the and
reclaim ensure you get the mention of
pure osho you test questions in the
mailbag and if that matters this is what
you get you get the leftist tears tumblr
mmm mmm mmm well they're very good this
is the avenatti brew I mean this is so
it's a little salty or a little spicier
you know it's coming up in greater
numbers you you used to be only to get
it when you do when you tune into CNN
now you can get a hand delivered in your
left the steers tumbler go to
we'll be right back
this idea of the language that we're all
using the the fantasies the speech the
lies that we're living in and the
reality on campuses even just looking at
campuses you see this even in hate
crimes in so-called hate crimes there we
are told that there is an epidemic of
racial hatred and bigotry spreading
throughout the country it's awful we
live in this terrible racist bigoted
place and the reality is we don't we
live in the most equitable fair just
free society in human history but
because we're saying that because we're
paying lip service to this lie to this
fantasy there is a cognitive dissonance
there and people on the Left have to go
in and try to make the reality the good
reality they're trying to make that fit
the terrible fantasy so they're trying
to make the reality works this just came
out today Finn a Johnny Arthur 21 year
old from Brunswick Maine was arrested at
6:00 p.m. couple days ago on the
Townsend campus and charged with two
counts of malicious destruction of
property
according to Baltimore County police the
malicious destruction of property was
that they found swastikas and the word
KKK spray-painted with the names of four
black students
spray-painted on the building so four
black students had their names swastika
KKK one of the students named spray
painted was Finn a Johnny Arthur they
said that this was a hate crime they
were gonna find the culprit who's the
culprit it's the kid himself he was he
was framing himself because he wanted to
tension because he wanted to call
attention to the hate crimes and the
racial bigotry that simply doesn't exist
because he's he knows he knows that this
country is so racist it's so awful it's
so terrible you say well show me
evidence of that he says I can't show
you evidence cousin this isn't good and
he's gonna make up his own evidence
Rachel Dahl is always doing this the
fake black woman the woman who pretended
to be black and darkened her skin she
would send hate mail and threatening
letters to herself as the head of her
local n-double-a-cp chapter these people
are insane obviously but it's not just
that it's not just that they're mentally
unbalanced you
not just that they want attention it's
that they are buying into a narrative
and they are frustrated every single day
that the narrative isn't true so they're
gonna make the narrative true
they are gonna bring racial prejudice
even if it's just a fiction even if it's
just a fantasy and we see these all the
time a while ago there was a black cadet
at the Air Force Academy who said he
found a racist message written in his
dorm guess who wrote the message he
wrote the message there was obviously
with the the rape hoax at UVA
Jackie Coakley I think it was who said
that she was gang-raped at this
fraternity at UVA turned out it was
totally false
she made it all up a ton of other sexual
assault hoaxes at the University of
Michigan a student faked an attack at a
Minnesota school that shut down classes
for a day because of a fake attack this
is not just an isolated incident it's
happening because people can't believe
that the reality doesn't match their
sick fantasy and it's much easier to to
not dislodge your wrong idea it's much
easier to just force reality to more
closely resemble the idea you see this
in transgenderism this is another
another aspect of this leftist ideology
where we know that the man who thinks
he's a woman is a man but rather than
change his mind and say he really is a
man he wants to change the reality to
appear more like the fantasy this is
this is true always of the left they are
so insisting on that you see this in all
of the utopian communist revolts they
say well human nature isn't behaving in
the way that you're saying it should
behave if they'll say well we're gonna
liquidate a few million more people well
we're gonna kill a few more people break
a few more eggs to make the omelet but
reality will kneel to my fantasies this
is the line quoted by Democrats RFK said
this he said George Bernard Shaw the
playwright George Bernard Shaw said some
people see things that are and ask why I
dream things that never were and ask why
not and the line he's quoting from Shaw
is from a play called back to Methuselah
and the line is actually in the mouth of
this the serpent tempting Eve it's the
words of the devil
who insists that we morph reality to fit
our own incorrect fantasies that's what
we're getting from the left and we
should mock them for it we should mock
these kids constantly Finn Ajani Arthur
20
one year old pretending that the white
people in his area are horrible racist
bigoted criminals
hey would-be criminals mock him
relentlessly for being wrong for being a
vandal for painting trying to paint his
his neighbors to be as sick and demented
as he is mock that it's crazy it's a
very good thing but their fantasies are
wrong because their fantasies are scary
and awful and bad it's a very good thing
that reality is as it is and we should
we should embrace them
speaking of fantasy and reality I can't
we can't we couldn't get through one
show without talking about the latest
gaffe from Alexandria Ocasio Cortese
Alexandria occasional cortex as Steve
Hayward describes though Casio Cortes
tweeted this out you just tweeted out I
think today or yesterday quote 21
trillion dollars of Pentagon financial
transactions could not be traced
documented or explained 21 trillion
dollars in Pentagon accounting errors
Medicare for all costs around 32
trillion dollars that means 66 percent
of Medicare for all
could have been funded already by the
Pentagon and that's before our premiums
so I you probably know this already
because I told you that Alexandria Casio
Cortez said it that isn't true that
isn't true at all the and so what
they're talking about 21 trillion
dollars gone missing from the Pentagon
there are reports about this that over
many many years they've lost track of
some money 21 trillion dollars but it
doesn't really mean that they lost 21
trillion dollars it means that the sum
total of all these little transactions
if you couldn't account for a little bit
here a little bit there or maybe you're
double counting money or whatever adds
up to 21 trillion dollars doesn't mean
that the money was wasted either it just
means it's not accounted for they don't
know where it is but it could have been
used on on anything and that number
could be much higher than the number
that was actually lost because of double
counting but it's not like the Pentagon
is funded for 21 trillion dollars she
you know the left the left really
benefits because people can't really
visualize the difference between a
million and a billion in a trillion
obviously their orders of magnitude
different but when we hear a million in
a billion
Trillian what what do you picture you
picture a really big number you picture
an unimaginably big number so really
numbers over a thousand we just sort of
lose track of them the actual budget of
the Pentagon is less than seven hundred
billion dollars a year six hundred
eighty 1.1 billion I believe per year so
the defense spending for the next ten
years is estimated around seven trillion
dollars that means that if you defunded
the entire military for a decade that
would only yield one-fifth of the cost
of Alexandria Ocasio Cortez's socialist
health care scheme she is saying you're
gonna you're gonna fund the vast
majority of socialist health care by
defunding the Pentagon you would have to
defund the Pentagon five times over to
fund this hozier socialist health care
scheme and of course you wouldn't even
fund it at that point because the costs
would increase dramatically
the trouble with socialist health care
is the costs are just gonna keep going
up there's no incentive to keep costs
down at all right and it's hard enough
in our current mixed system to keep
costs down with us so many flaws in our
health care system but once you've got
single-payer once you've got a socialist
health care you're gonna have a huge
decrease in innovation you're gonna have
long wait lines you're gonna have people
abusing the system just like government
employees always abuse the system
because there isn't much incentive not
to so just consider those numbers you
got to defund the entire Pentagon five
times over and and do it does anybody
want to do that do we think that's a
good idea
for the last superpower on earth to not
have a military or intelligence services
or to have any of that ports not she
keeps tweeting it's funny because I
thought her Twitter account was now
being run by the staff because she
stopped saying things that were
extraordinarily ignorant they were only
mostly ignorant but maybe she hops on
every once in a while or maybe her staff
doesn't know very much imagine the kind
of person who decides to work for
Alexandria or Cassio Cortes imagine the
kind of person who thinks this is the
this is who I will follow into battle
this is who I think should be leading
our country that's the kind of person
sending out those tweets but it's just
wrong and I'm sure we're gonna call
Alexandria CAHSEE of Cortes out on this
she still hasn't deleted the tweet and
she's gonna say well we'll just pay for
it
stop catcalling me
stop okay that's fine but it's just one
more time showing you the people who are
begging for socialist health care can't
explain how we're gonna get it because
they say you know it's it's so
outrageous they say I'm I'm for good
things for everybody I want to give good
things to everybody that's my position
and the II mean old conservatives want
don't want good things for everybody we
say well no we want we want good things
for people how are you gonna pay for
those good things they say stop asking
me those questions you say you can't get
the political benefit of saying I want
to get all the good things and then not
deal with the reality of it it's such
demagoguery it's so ignorant and but
this is this is the future of the
Democrat Party before we go I do want to
point out one other aspect where the
left is constantly getting things wrong
tumblr do you know tumblr tumblr is this
blogging site where it's a lot of mostly
pictures and people put their art there
and a lot of people put porn on there a
tumblr was purchased by Yahoo I believe
a little while ago and tumblr announced
yesterday they were gonna take all the
pornography off of their website and the
left was furious about this they said
how dare you take away this or this
expression apparently one fifth of
tumblr users at least go on the site
looking for porn so it's really gonna
hit their stock and hit their company so
this is awful this is not this is
terrible for people the reason that
tumblr had to do this is apparently
there's a lot of child pornography on
their website and nobody is policing it
and this is obviously a huge criminal
matter it doesn't look right for
business really bad for kids so they're
saying okay we're gonna take all adult
material off there this is a really
tough spot it's another wedge issue for
the left which is they've got a neo
Puritanism when it comes to sex and an
absurd libertinism they've got both of
those at the same time so they're the
people who say we need to host sex week
at all these universities we need to we
need to legalize polygamy we need all
love is love and anything you want to do
sexually is good and wonderful and
should be celebrated if it feels good do
it
you should slap people around and engage
in whatever sort of weird kinky desires
you have and engage in those and that's
perfectly fine
also if a man tries to kiss a woman it's
ray
also which one is it which is the what
is it we all we should have if they say
we should have a ton of porn on these
websites we should have even if it even
if that means that some child porn is
going to slip through there but also if
a man kisses a woman it's rape and
misogyny which is that they're really
torn on this because the natural
conclusion of a totally free
pornographic website without any
oversight whatsoever is you're gonna get
illegal pornography on there child
pornography other other illegal
pornography and nobody wants that so
they're torn because they want to be
able to have the licentiousness but they
don't want to have to deal with the
downside of the licentiousness they want
the hook-up culture because it seems so
independent and people get to do
whatever they want but then they don't
want to deal with sexual regret on the
other side and they're losing their
minds it's making them crazy if they
only realize it if you have a a middle
ground you hold things in balance you
deal with things in a mature way they
probably would be able to split this but
in the meantime they're just going to
keep suffering from cognitive dissonance
and you're going to have lefties on
Twitter defending Tumblr's child
pornography that is that is the logical
conclusion of that that's our show for
the day we got a lot more to get to but
we'll have to do it tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knoll show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018